我们这时候就可以表达每一个joint它的姿态了
那回到刚才我们讲的
就是说其实joint它首先有一个叫orientation
orientation这个词呢其实跟rotation呢也很像
但是rotation更平民一点
orientation呢更能表达它叫空间上的朝向
那么空间上的朝向的话呢
它实际上呃就是说在我的每个joint在任何时候
实际上都是它有各种各样的朝向的变化
这里面有个细节
就是说在大量的动画里面
大量的关节实际上它的运动都是以orientation
就是以旋转为主
其实如果我们把关节只看它和它的腹部之
间的关系的时候
你会发现他很多时候不会发生平移
也不会发生放松
只有旋转
所以旋转的表达是动画的一个最核心的东西
那么就是说另外一个呢
joint pose表达就是它的位置
这个位置呢指的就是空间上的平移
这个位置呢像我讲了两个joint之间
其实一般来讲不会变
就比如说我的父joint定在这的时候
我的子joint他的position一般就是一个常数
不会变的对吧
你的负负骨骼转了之后
我相信的也就跟着转
但是呢在游戏引擎里面这个数值还是有用的
为什么呢
有些特殊的情况
你比如说我们的人的那个PVS尾椎骨骼
它相对root的话
当这个人蹲在那儿站起来的时候
他的位置position是不是发生了变化
对不对
那么我整个这个角色站立和蹲下
都是要靠这根p vs骨骼顶起来
所以这个骨骼有很多的平移的变化
那么第二个呢就是刚才我讲了
就是在人的这个表情动画里面
其实呢也有很多的平移的这个变化
还有呢就是在一些特殊的机械结构里面
比如说我们要做一个古代的弩
弩箭这个弩箭它会拉开松起
拉开松起
那这个骨骼呢实际上也有这样的一个平移变化
但是在其他地方
如果你加了平移变化之后
这个角色看上去就会非常的奇怪
对吧嗯
那么joint这个姿态也是大家比较难理解的
就是它的放缩变化
放缩变化呢实际上我们一般时候都会用
所以你如果看大量动画数据的话
scale这一项的话就是这个POS数据一般都是一一
大家都不懂
但是呢在在有些场合我们用的还是蛮多的
比如说在我们的面部的表达的时候
我要做给他做个大眼睛
小眼睛对吧
我做个大鼻头高鼻头诶
这个时候我们会用到它的这个放缩的变化
而且放缩这里面我沿着X轴
Y轴
Z轴的放缩比例可能都不一样
比如说我想做个阴沟比
还有我想做个很塌的鼻子
这个时候我就会用到它的这个这个
这个这个技术
所以呢这也是在动画中
有的时候我们用到的一个技术好
那其实对于任何一个joint一个关节
它的姿态的话呢
实际上我们可以把它分解成三个元素旋转旋转
刚才我讲了
他是一个四元数对吧
那任何一个四元数呢
我可以把它展开成一个3×3的旋转矩阵
对不对
那么它的平移我们可以再转换成也是一个啊
就是那个3×3的这样的一个一个矩阵
我们还有什么呢
还有放缩
那这里面的话呢
就是当我们把所有东西放在一起的时候
其实啊我们可以形成一个
就是这个一个一个3×3的
我们叫做啊应该是3×4的
一个叫a fine matrix
那为什么呢
因为我们在表达平移的时候
实际上我们要加一个额外的是XYZ
还加上个一
那个一的话就是拼音
但是这里面的话呢就是说这个a fan matrix啊
实际上它和我们在做那个投影的那个
那个那个矩阵不一样
投影矩阵的话呢
他的那个就是最后你算出来
他那个坐坐标XYZW的时候
你要把X除以WY除以WZ
它除以W才能表表示
这种就是就是透视变化对吧
但是呢在骨骼动画里面的话
它这个矩阵我们叫做反射反射矩阵
它实际上是一个3×4的矩阵
它下面那个零零内列其实是不需要的
为什么呢
因为它永远是正交投影
大家仔细想就知道他永远是正交投影
所以这个矩阵呢其实是非常重要的
实际上这也是我们在游戏里面对对骨骼
对顶点进行运算的核心数据系统
那么它的数据语言就是我刚才讲的旋转
我用四元数表达你ABCD对吧
你的你的TRC
你的translation
你的平移
我用德尔塔XYZ表达放缩呢
我可以用就是那个AAASS
ASBC或者SXXYSZ来表达
我就能表达成一个反射矩阵
到这1part的话
同学们没有跟丢吧
就是这个这就是你的joint的
表达了最核心的一个矩阵
那这个时候呢
我们当我们去表达一个joint的时候呢
哎这个地方开始有数学符号了啊
他真正的做法
动画呢我们一般都会存储在他的local space里面
就是说我只会去成相对于他的父亲的这个变化
为什么呢
因为你会发现当一个角色在动的时候
很多骨骼其实是没有任何动画的
或者它只有一点点的旋转
所以的话呢我们实际上对于每个骨骼来讲的话
我们知道几个概念
第一就是说我自身的这个复骨骼是谁
第二就是说我的这个腹骨骼
它在local space里面到底长什么样
那接下来我要求的东西是什么呢
就是我这个骨骼
我这个joint我也讲错了
就这个这个关节
它在是在模型坐标
坐标系里面应该是什么样子的
那这个怎么做呢
实际上它是从他的这个根节点开始
一个骨骼
一个骨骼算下来
刚才我们是讲了
你会得到这样一个反射矩阵嘛对吧
那它具体怎么算呢
实际上哦我们怎么讲了这个interpolation了
哎呀好吧
我先这个地方这个地方我觉得讲的是有点难了
那我先讲一下
就是为什么我们要把这个动画数据
全部存到这个局部坐标系呢
其实它有一个数学原理的
就是说
当我的动画如果全部存在模型坐标系的时候
我因为我从第一个这个姿态到第二个字
代价是这样
如果我们每个关节点啊
它假设是在世界坐标啊
在模型坐标系差值的时候
它插出来的动作啊
你的骨骨头它会一会变长
一会变的
为什么呢
因为如果你在模型这边也差值的话
你插出来的是条直线
大家看对不对
他两个位置变的时候
它它的joint顶点位置它就会变成一条直线
那个骨骼看上去就是诶
就是他是走就是两点之间
比如说我第一针
我的我的我的胳膊在这儿对吧
我的第二针胳膊在这儿
那我的胳膊这个轴脚是不动的话
你发现没有
你插出来的这个这个两个joint的位置
是不是正好在一个三角形
大家看我们的这个右边这个图就是model spy差值
但这个显然和我们人的认知是不一样对吧
而我们应该真正差指的是什么呢
是这两个joint
这这这个joint的话
它的rotation
那么这个rotation的差值累积上去的话呢
你看到的就是一个骨骼
在定场的这样的一个旋转
所以说动画系统用局部坐标系进行插值的话
它是有很深的一个数学原理在里面的
而这个时候呢我们先讲一个最简单的原理
就是说假设我只我的一个点
它只跟一根骨骼关联
记注意啊
一个顶点就是我在模型上的一个顶点
和一个骨骼关联
大家特别容易搞混的东西是什么呢
我的骨骼
我的joint在这儿对吧
但是我跟他关联的这个这个顶点
在另外一个地方
它们之间是什么呢
还有一个相对位移的
大家仔细想是不是这样的对吧
那我现在这个joint它本身动了
发生平移
发生旋转的时候
我希望我表皮上的这个这个皮肤
上的这个这个mesh也跟着相应动
这两个之间的数学是怎么去映射过来的
其实比大家想象的要复杂
那这里面我怎么去表达它呢
其实他在数学上我们可以这么看
就是说对于任何一个顶点
一开始我人在a pose的时候
他呢这个顶点在模型空间
是不是有个有一个位置对吧
我们叫做那个V
这个V呢我们用上表表达它是在哪个space里面
它在模型空间
mage表示它在模型空间里面
那么他那个B就表示是在绑定的时候位置对吧
那这个时候呢我的这个V啊
就是在那个local space的话
相对那个绑定的那个那个那个骨骼的话
实际上也是有一个位置叫VBL对吧
那这个时候呢
我相对于我的这个这个绑在绑定的时候呢
我实际上是他那个那个骨骼啊
在mod设备里面有一个绑定
那个joint
有个绑定的矩阵
刚才我们不是定义了一个FMRX吗
那个绑定矩阵它其实呢要满足一个恒等式
就是如果你这个绑定关系不变的话
当我这个joint的无论在空间上怎么移动
怎么旋转对吧
我实际上我把我的这个顶点在local space
就相对你那个joint看上去的那个位置
和你一开始绑定的时候
它两个数据是不能变的
大家仔细看我们在这边画的这张图
就是右边这张图就是一开始的话
在第绑定的时候
假设我们有个logo
那个标价我中间也有一个点
蓝色那个点
它相对于那个标价的话是个固定的位置对吧
当我的这个标价就是local space在被动的时候
再动到T的这一帧的时候
那他的那个新的那个黄色的点
它在它的两个局部坐标向上投影
是不是要严格一致
否则这就不叫绑定了对吧
所以这样你会出现就是当这个关节在动的时候
这上面的表皮就跟着动
所以你会发现这里面有这样的一个恒等式
这个恒等式里面有个关键的矩阵
就是说这一根骨骼在它绑定姿态的时候
它在模型坐标系里面的那个transform
就是那个翻译
那个那个那个那个那个叫fine matrix
那个叫什么来着
哎呀我老是反应不过来
就是他那个叫反射变换的一个矩阵
这个矩阵是它最核心的一个矩阵
而且呢我们要求就是任何时候
当你这个肩关节点动了之后
我实际上我们两个的相对关系不能发生变化
我们只考虑一个
就是说一个骨骼的情况下
那这个时候呢我们去看一个概念
就是说实际上我们的任何一个点
他在就任何一个关节
它在单位时间T的时候
它的在模型空间的位置啊
实际上你可以认为它从根节点的那个
模型空间的那个那个那个矩阵一路的垒成上来
这个是没有问题的
就是就是一个transform叠一个穿刺孔
最后叠叠到我的手这个地方的这个矩阵
那么我实际上要满足的
就是刚才讲的那个恒等式
就是说我的V在任何时候它在模型空间的位置
就是这个顶点变的那个位置
实际上等于什么呢
等于它的那个就是说他在绑定pose
那个矩阵的逆乘上呢
就是说在我的这个model space的时候
那个那个那个那个joint
他在那个T的那个时刻的反射矩阵乘上呢
我在绑定时候的那个位置的相对关系
就是大家不要这个推导
大家自己可以推导一下
其实讲起来很抽象
但是简单来讲的话
就是说我在这个顶点在绑定的时候有个位置
我乘上
我在绑定的时候
我这个上我的腹关节的
我绑定的关节的那个就是仿射矩阵的逆
我现在知道我们的相对位置
当你的这个关节这个这个位置呢
在模型空间已经发生了很多变化的时候
我把这个相对位置再乘上
你这个变化
就可以得到我现在新的模型空间里面的这个值
所以这个值呢是就是我的新的坐标值
就这件事情其实大家经常在做这个东西的时候
经常会忘记什么事
就把那个逆矩阵乘上去
就绑定的那个逆矩阵
所以我们在计算机运算的时候
在做那个动画的时候
我们一般在每一根骨骼
我们存的就是它的这个叫它的这个逆矩阵
再乘上它的这个
就是说它当前动的在模型空间的矩阵
这个矩阵叫什么呢
就是我们叫做skinny matrix
skinny matrix就是我们的动画矩阵
就是我给你这个模型上的任何一个点
说只要你绑定
比如说032号骨骼
你就要找到032和骨骼的这个skinny matrix
你把他在绑定的时候
你原始mesh里面的坐标的XYZ乘上这个sky mamx
就是这个骨架动过之后它的位置
所以这里面的运算的话是要有把把一个绑定的
一个逆矩阵放进去的
所以这个时候我们去看那个
就是我们怎么去在计算机里面去存一个
股价信息的时候
你们如果看任何一个引擎的实现的时候
你会发现它除了传我们所知道的
就是绑定的时候
比如说它的位置
他的放松放松一般是一一嘛就不动了对吧
还包括什么呢
还包括他的这个这个就是哦
那个那个那个QUATAN的rotation对吧
就表达在空间的旋转
实际上它一般会存一个就是这个这根joint呢
这根关节在绑定的时候
它在空模型空间的那个那个那个变化的那个
它的逆矩阵在那
为什么呢
因为我在运算的时候
当我动股价的时候
我会算出来这个joint的话
在新的动画pose下
它在模型空间的那个就是那个transform
那这两个transform呢
我要把这两个乘到一起
就得到了他的skinny matrix
而这个SKINMATRIX的话
实际上就是当我知道这
当我在做vertex的这个空间的这个绘制的时候
我把老的这个模meshing的位置
乘上这个skinny的matrix的话
就是他新的位置
所以这个实际上是
当大家再去做动画系统的时候
一定要牢记这个公式
这个公式是非常非常重要的一个公式
那么我们有了假设我这个人有70根骨骼对吧
那我把对骨骼进行编号
01234567
一直到69~70
那实际上我算出来所有的这些skinny matrix的话
它形成一个就是pilot
就是一个一个表
也就是说因为我为什么要算这个表呢
其实很简单
就当我正式绘制的时候
我这一个角色身上的顶点输出多少呢
可能是几万个对吧
那这几但是呢我的骨骼就几十个
所以说呢我不应该在每次算一个顶点的时候
我去再去算这个骨骼应该怎么样
我是要先把所有的骨骼它的位置算好
算好之后呢
我把他的这个就是那个蒙皮的矩阵送啊
送送算好
那这样的话当我这些顶点用的时候
我就可以重用这些蒙皮矩阵的这些纸
那这个事情非常的重要
为什么呢
因为我们接下来会讲的就是说它这个母体啊
实际上是有很多的权重加在一起的
那我实际上每一个那个每一个蒙
就是每一个joint这个矩阵会被访问很多很多次
所以必须得一圈算好
但这里面还有一个细节
就是刚才我们讲的就是
我们有三个三个坐标系嘛对吧
从我们这里面讲的最多的是模型坐标系
但是呢这个模型本身在空间上是不是有位移
所以呢在游戏引擎里面
我们一般呢就是对这个磨皮矩阵的这个PALEA
会把它在世界坐标系里的那个那个transform
也会乘上去
就是我们会再乘上一个矩阵
就是从模型坐标系向世界坐标系的
这个transform我也乘上去
所以你真正看到的这个skinny matrix呢
应该是就是这样的一个形式
就是说它最外端是模型向世界的转换
第二个呢是你这个joint就是你依赖的这根骨骼
他在模型坐标系里面
最后它的这个pose是什么
就是它的变化是什么
然后呢要乘上一个
就是你在绑定的时候
这个就是这个这个joint
它在它在模型坐标系里面的
这个这个这个这个transfer transform
就是变形的这个逆是什么
这三个乘到一起
就构成了我们的一个矩阵的pallet
这个地方稍微有点抽象
如果同学们听不懂没关系
就是说你可以反复的来回推
因为刚才跟大家讲
就是在这边的公式里面
其实这个恒等式非常重要
也就是说下面那个就是你会它核心讲的道理
就是说如果我的一个顶点相对于某一个joint
就是某一个关键点绑定之后
无论你撞的怎么动我
我这个顶点所在的新的位置
它相对于你这个就joint
相对于这个空间关系的话永远是不变的
它其实整个就是用这个恒等去推出来
这个所有的绑定的原理
其实这个恒等的话
你把两边同时乘上一个矩阵的逆的话
你会发现它这个等式就变成了
我们这边的这个等式
所以的话呢这就是这个就是skinny matrix的话
最核心的两个运算
第一个运算就是上一节上那个上上一个公司
就是说我的每一根骨骼
它是从根节点用local的transform
一路累积上来的对吧
这个transform要包括旋转
平移放缩一路上来对吧
那么第二趴呢
就是说我一旦一路把他的在模型空间的变形
给他算出来之后
那我对于所有绑定的点
它的新的位置怎么算呢
我要承受你绑定时候的矩阵能力
再乘上你当前的这个
你在模型空间的那个那个那个那个位移
那个那个那个那个就pose矩阵
然后呢我就能得到你的skinny matrix
这样的话我就能算出我的心的位置
那么我在真正渲染的时候呢
我再加上一个
就是说你的从模型坐标系向世界坐标系的转换
那么这个时候我才能算出来
那么我们在做引擎的时候呢
我们在数据结构里面
会提前的把它矩阵的逆给存好
为什么呢
因为大家如果学过线性代数
就知道我给你任何一个矩阵
虽然这个矩阵它是一个正交啊
它是一个就是A翻译矩阵
他的力是可以相对快的求导
但是本身还是比较慢
所以呢我们会提前把它矩阵的逆给求好
那这个就会预先存好
所以说大家如果想做动画系统的话
这四页是很关键的事业
就是其实做动画系统我觉得就两个数学吧
第一个就是说COTAN的力东西要理解透
第二个呢
就是这个矩阵怎么一步步的去运算过来
这一排要理解透
基本上你就可以去写这个
我们的这个这个这个动画了
那么接下来的话呢所谓的蒙皮动画
实际上呢它只是在这个基础上
让我们的一个顶点啊
任何一个表面上的点
能够和多个joint同时起作用
就多个关节起作用
那它这个joint它的原理其实非常的简单
就是加权平均
那么他要求就是说诶我每一个顶点啊
就每一个那个表面上的点
它会和不止一个joint起作用
一般来讲的话呢这个数量它可以不设上限的
但是一般来讲我们会不超过四个
就是说当我们要求相应的所有受他影响了
骨骼的话呢
它的加权必须要等于一
如果不等于一的话
就会出现很多很奇怪的变形
那么当我有了这个vt sky的话
我怎么去算出它新的位置呢
其实这个过程呢就非常的直觉和简单
就是说我相对于我的依赖的joint1
我要算出我在模型空间的这个坐标系
对吧哦
我的我的我的新的坐标
我在相对于我的joint的二
我也算出我的像在那个模型空间的第二个坐标
这两个坐标用一个加权
就是你一开始给的权做个平均就出来了
那这里面有个细节也是非常重要的
就是这个差值呢它必须是在模型空间
不能够在joint the local space
为什么
因为local space每个joint都不一样
对不对
比如说这是joint的
一是joint的二对吧
那我joint的一转成这样了
但joint那我还加了个旋转
那这个地方假设我的表皮有一个顶点
有一个有一个点的话
那其实呢我要用这个句型来算出它的新的位置
再用这个卷子算出另外二个位置
然后呢他两个在一起的话
其实就能形成我们想要的那种twist的这个效果
所以这个是就是大家做真正的蒙皮动画的时候
注意所有的这个就是顶点的这个差值
一定是在模型坐标里做完
不
千万不能在local spss
local space里面做
LOCPA1做你肯定就完蛋了
它实际上它也差不了好
那实际上呢我们有了这样的一些数学基础的话
我们就可以完全的进行我们的动画系统了
那这里面的话呢
就是当我们一帧帧的pose做的连接在一起
这个呢我们在动画里面一般叫做一个CLIPSE
就是就是一组动画
我们家就我们或者叫做一个动画
克里斯在中国也不知道怎么翻译
就是说一个动画资产嘛
就是我一个比一个走路的克里斯
我有个跳跃的clips
我有个跑步的clips
那么就是说真实在渲染的时候呢
其实我们会对他做什么做差值
因为CLIPSE的它一般存比如15帧或者20帧
但是我们在游戏游戏里面的话呢
我的真的密度是很高
想象一下
比如说我们现在游戏里面一般是多少帧
120帧
60帧
对不对
但我动画资产不可能存60帧
存120帧
所以很多时候呢我们要在这两个pose之间去插值
那差值呢
其实就是说它能够让这个动画
看起来更加的平滑
那差值呢这边我就讲的比较简单一点
比如说如果我对于我的这个就是位移
对于我的scale
大家用线性插值基本上就都能看了
但是呢比较复杂的是rotation
那么rotation怎么做呢
实际上那个我们前面讲了quota嘛对吧
假设你一开始的旋转就是第一针的时候
哎你这个joint的logo是Q1
第二种是Q2
那它的差值呢
实际上就是Q1和Q2的线性差值
再加个什么呢
再加上一个normalization
这样的话你就能得到一个旋转
就像这个右边的下面这个图一样的
所以这个差值我们叫什么叫安乐
就是normalize
我的这个NERP它就可以旋转
这个呢其实在啊游戏引擎里面用的非常多
就是CORTANA一个很大的好处
就是说如果你这时候给我的这个欧拉角的话
表达了旋转
或者你给我的是用那个就是矩阵transform rotation
矩阵表达旋转
我给你一个矩阵一和矩阵二是表达两个旋转
我问他们之间怎么插值
实际上同学们想一想
这个计算其实非常的麻烦的
就是说至少我现在没有想出来说如果不用HOTAN
我怎么去做动画系统
我我我
我觉得就是说哈密尔顿
几乎给出了我们这个行业的唯一解
那么NNP呢它其实是一个有一个细节
就是说其实角度差值为什么它很复杂
就是rotation的差值
实际上它有一个就是叫最短路径的原则
就是说两个旋转从旋转一插向旋转二人的
以我们的人的perception的直觉
一般你都要沿着球面最短的路径
这就相当于是比如说你从北京到新疆对吧
你从北京直接飞过去
从北京飞到新疆是最短路径
但是呢你其实从北京往美国飞
然后然后沿着太平洋
沿着大西洋
再从欧洲整个一路撞回来
你穿过亚欧大陆
你其实你也得到新疆
但是你那个路径是不是
它就是不符合人的直觉了
所以呢在这个地方呢我们加一个小小的运算
就是说唉我们把CORTANA1dot product的口袋生二
这个值我得到的是大于零小于零
其实这个大于零小于零就代表了
如果是大于零
你就直接插上就好
如果是小于零的话呢
大于180度的角
你就反向去查查就好了
那这个其实是一个很重要的处理
那这个东西如果你不去做的话
我们在我们在小引擎里面
其实已经做了这个处理
你看的就是这个角色的动画
如果那个你不去做这种最短路径的差值的话
你会发现在某些时候那个关节会突然做个翻转
但是呢你加了这个最短路径的差值呢
诶他会看上去相对自然一点
所以这是啊小运行一个很重要的一个
一个一个一个属性好
那么在现在3A游戏中的话呢
就是你会发现
就是说即使有这样的一个cod的差值
它有一个小小的问题
就是说它其实在角度空间中的这个差值旋转
就是你比如说你把它参数从00~11点点的
变的时候
它的速度是不均匀的
你会发现就是他一开始就是到中间慢
到后面又开始快
它是一个
就是你如果对一个质量要求很高的动画的话呢
你会发现这个东西看上去有点不自然
所以呢现在在三游戏中
大家提出了一个叫SLP的概念
那SROP呢实际上也很简单
就是说我把两个旋转之间的夹角theta给找出来
他用了一个阿克cos的运算
找出它的theta
然后呢我用那个theta哎一点点的差值
这个效果是比较好的
但是这个差值呢就是第一个它比较费
它有一个反三角函数的运算对吧
我们都知道在计算机里面进行这种三角函数
特别是反三角形运算
它是很废的
它是要查表的
我不太可能现在在实时的真的去算
我要去查表去算
那么另外一个的话呢
就是当C塔非常小的时候
那这个就是那个那个因为你用sin theta
就是因为你知道就theta很小
sin theta是不是很小
对不对
那这个你用它做分母
其实这个差值啊
它本身是不稳定的
所以真正的在我们游戏的实践中呢
一般来讲会给定一个magic number
这个两个CORTAN就是两个旋转镜的夹角
如果它很小
我就不折腾了
用最简单的ENERP差值就完事了
但是呢如果两个夹角比较大的话
哎我就用SLP
其实这两个方法都比较简单
如果同学们在写引擎的时候呢
我会建议按这个方法实现
基本上你能够达到这一代的这个效果
包括我们的小引擎
其实小引擎现在我们只用了ENERP的方法
那我们后面的话可能就是说不定出个作业
让同学们写个s lf joint的共同方法
也就能帮助大家理解
CORTI和整个这个动画的这个运算好
那么其实讲到这儿啊
其实动画的最核心的数学和它的原理
就讲完了对吧
虽然不好意思
我今天又超时了一一小时
38分钟了对吧
但是的话呢就是说呃
确实一个简单的动画系统给大家讲明白了
真的需要这么久
那么这里面的话呢就是一个简单的动画
Rua pipeline
就是我首先呢有大量的动画的clips对吧
然后呢我们在每一帧都是我CLIPSE
就存在这个角色的各个pose
对不对
那我就会找的就是它的当前帧和它的下一帧
其实我们这里的frame和post的概念是很相似的
然后这个时候呢
我们就算出它的这个就是interplay
就刚才我们讲的差值算法差
除它现在真正的股价应该在这个pose
然后这个pose呢我会把它转换成model space里面对吧
我把它算好
算好之后就用刚才我讲的那个数学方法
我把它算成我们的skinny matrix palate
就是说每一根骨骼表达成一个他的skinny magic
这样的话注意在这一趴的时候
一般来讲我们就会从CPU的运算
像GPU的运算的一个转换
就显卡运算
就前面这一发传统的游戏引擎里面
都是在这个CPU算完的
但是后面这一盘呢我们一般会交给GPU啊
GPU里面的话呢
在他的word shader里面
我的每一个顶点就是几万个顶点
几百万个
假设有skinny的这个顶点一般没有那么多了
就可以带ski的对象的话
一般在游戏里面也就是几十个到上百个
那么每一个的话几千个上万个点不同
然后呢他们就开始用这个这些这些skinny matrix
真的让这些角色活灵活现的动起来
但是呢其实现在的游戏引擎里面
我一般讲叫GPU driven
实际上前面的那部分运算
现在也越来越多的游戏
特别是主流的3A游戏的话
我们基本上也是全放在GPU里面去算了
因为这个CPU算实在是没有必要对吧
所以这个就是一个非常简单的动画的软弹
PAPI讲到这儿
基本上你的游戏就可以去做了
但是呢你真实的在游戏中啊
还有一个很常见的一个技术就是动画压缩
那么动画压缩为什么很重要呢
实际上是我们会发现动画数据存储啊
它的数据量不像大家想象的那么小
那我举个游戏的例子吧
就比如说在一个游戏里面
比如说以撸啊撸为例
我有100多个英雄对吧
每个英雄大概有5~10秒的这种动画
每一个动画呢一秒钟我要存30帧
30帧里面我要存它的这个平移
放缩和旋转的数据
这个加在一起
大家算一下
你会发现就这么一个简单的case
你的数动画数据量将近两到三个G了
那这个数据量其实不能忽视的
其实现在游戏特别是3A游戏的话
它的动画量比这个还要大
因为我的模型的这个
这个就是因为你比如一个角色
一个动画
它实际上是有70个70个关节嘛对吧
那70个关节的话
每个关节在每隔三每秒钟要存30个它的pose
每个pose里面又包括它的平移旋转和放缩
所以这个数据量非常的大
但是呢动画数据呢你仔细观察
你会发现很有意思的特点
就是说其实对于同一个joint
你去看它
它很多数据是不变的
比如说大部分的骨骼
它的放缩是都是一个常数
就是一对吧
那么它的对大部分骨骼在local space看过了
就刚才我一直在讲
就说哎他的那个就是位移其实也是不变的
对不对
因为我这个这个这个joint
和这个joint之间的位移
只要我这个骨骨头不打断
它一直都是连在一起的对吧
那么它大量的数据是什么呢
是rotation
那么其实就算是rotation呢
你会发现啊
就是当我们表达很多角色动作的时候
你比如说像他的手指上
当他走的时候
他的手指头不会一边走
还一边捏来捏去
对不对
很多时候他的手的这个手指头的这些这些
这很多十几根骨骼
它几乎没有什么rotation的动画
然后呢上臂呢虽然有一些
但是呢它的幅度也很小
但是你的大腿一块抬起来
一块放下去
所以这边的数据它又会又会不一样
所以当我们观察到动画数据这个性质的时候
我们实际上就知道
怎么去降低它的数据的难度了啊
数据的量了
第一种方法呢就是说哎我们对于你那些不变的
那些就是那些track
我们直接把你干掉
比如说scale
你干掉translation呢
我不要存那个沿时间轴和一串
我只要存一个值就完事了对吧
这个是非常常用的
也是很常见的一个东西
我们很快就能定义说哪些骨骼完全没有
就是位移变化好
那这个时候这个时候呢对于rotation的话
我们压缩的方法引入一个关键的概念
就是k friend的观念
就是关键帧的概念
关键帧的意思就是说你的整个这个运动啊
这些信号
其实我可以用一些关键帧别拉出来之后
在关键帧帧之间差值我就能表达
你那这个k phone之间的差值呢其实也非常的简单
它就是跟我们前面讲的MARSHIN的算法
比如说我先选取时间零零作为第一个关键帧
我就依次往前走走走走走
在走的下个点之间
我们线性差值
当你的就是原始的数值和我差值出来的值
之间的误差超过了一定阈值的时候
诶我就把那个点退回来
把上一个点就输出它的关键帧
然后再以它为起点再往前插对吧
就是一个martin算法
我永远保证你的error小于我的阈值
那我这个我就可以把原来
比如说几百帧的这个动画变成几十个关键帧
连接在一起的这样的一个动画
那这些关键帧注意啊
它关键帧和关键帧之间的时间间距是不均等的
这取决于你的信号
在这个时间轴上的变化的频率
但这种差值呢对于旋转来讲的话呢
其实还是不太符合他真实的数据
我们去观察一下
就是说其实啊在关节的旋转数据啊
即使你表达成CORTINA
它实际上很多时候是一个光滑的一个弧线
那么我们如果用线性差值的话呢
他很多时候表达的误差会很大
很就是你会要加很多的关键帧
但是线性差值的好处是什么呢
就是在RUNTIME的时候
我计算很复杂很简单
而这里面的话呢就会引入大名鼎鼎的cut more曲线
对吧
卡通木曲线是一个非常经典的一个
就是polynomial
就是多项式的一个曲线
它基本上就是三阶吧
那么这里面它有个参数叫阿尔法
就是它叫它叫锐度
一般我们只用阿尔法等于0.5
那么你给定任何两个点P1P2
你在他就P1往外延拖一个就是P0那个点
P2往前拖一个P3那个点
那么你就可以定义的一个叫C0和C1连续的
这样的一个一个一个多项式曲线
这个曲线的话呢
你用这个方程去表达它就是那个曲线
这个曲线的话呢实际上是非常光滑的
很好看
那么这个呢就是我今天不不不展开了
因为今天课程的量有点大
但是同学们这应该是一个will study的一个problem
基本上你做任何一个东西
你都要用的cut more曲线的
那么你有了卡拉莫曲线之后
你会发现
我们去逼近一个真实的rotation的信号的时候
我们用的k phone的数量就会少很多
而且呢差值的时候
这个精度也会更好控制
这里面就是一个真实的案例
就是我们拿了一个真实动画的一个rotation
的一个数据
然后呢用cut more曲线就一点一点的去逼近它
而这个过程的话呢
呃其实它都是离线计算的
所以大家不用担心这个计算很复杂
因为到实时的时候
你你就你只能看到控制点
你最多只需要拿四个点的数据
用一个多项式计算机就能查出它的值
那么基本上用这个这是整个曲线的差值
那么对于他数值表达呢
我们也不会那么傻
就是说对于它的位移啊
对于他的这个这个旋转都用那个那个浮点数
浮点数我在前面也讲过
浮点数32位对吧
32个beat
那它的存储量是非常大
压力也很大的
那这里面有一个很简单的方法
就是如果你的这个数字在数值在一个空间的话
其实呢我可以用一个定点数来模拟你
它的基本思想呢也很简单
比如说假设我知道一个数值
它的范围假设是负
比如说50~120多
那实际上我可以把这个区间啊
把它规划到0~1上面
这样你在里面任何一个数值的话
我可以比如用16位的这个整数来表达
你如果这个时候你用16位整数表达
你可以发现你可以表达到0.01
甚至更低一点的这个精度啊
更更更密的这个精度
更高的这个精度
而这个对于很多的数值表达来讲
其实就已经够了
那这里面的话呢
就是说那我们怎么对四元数进行定点化的
这个数值压缩呢
这里面就要利用到四元数的一个
很有意思的数学特性
当我们对四元数进行归一化压缩的时候
你会发现
虽然每每一个数值都有可能在正一之间波动
但是呢你把那个最大的那个数扔掉的话
其他三个数值啊
它一定会小于正二分之根号二
也就意味着是说
我只需要拿两位的这个哪两个beat存
是哪一个位是最大值
那剩下的三个那个值的话
我把它存下来
我就可以通过规划反向算法
可以还原整个四元数
这个就是一个非常重要的观察
那这样的话我们在工业上就会发现
就是说你把他的这个虚部的三个量啊
用大概是15个
就是比特就可以把它表达得非常的准确
所以在工业上我们去压缩一个四元数的时候
并不是傻乎乎的
存了四个float
大家想想它的多大
就是一个float
四个BT对吧
四个float呢我们要再存啊
16个BT
这是很很废的
但是呢在我们的这个这个表达
你们拿一个四元数
我只要48个bit
48个币多少呢
就是六个BT
就我家大概压缩掉了将近70%以上的
这个呃对60%多吧
这个额外的空间这个其实是非常的有用
所以动画数据的压缩啊
对于所有的引擎来讲
都是非常重要的一个一个一个东西
那这个的话呢
就是如果我们做一个真正的实战的
游戏引擎的话
动画数据也是一定要压缩
但是呢做小引擎的时候其实是不需要的
比如像我们的PIO引擎
因为时间紧张
我们也不想搞得太复杂
所以我们的数据是没有压缩的
但是如果你真的要把它改成实战的话
同学们一定要加入它的压缩算法在里面
那么这里面给大家讲一下
就是压缩其实会带来很多的问题
就是说虽然我每个关节的动画压缩的时候呢
我都把他的error控制住了
但是因为我们的动画是什么
它是从一个关节传递到下一个关节
对不对
大家用很自然的方法去想一想
这个error会不会一直叫propagation
就是说一直传递下去
也就是说当你在这个地方
前面几个骨骼看的时候
它的error还可以
但是当你从这个PV
一路传递到我的手指尖的时候
哎这个error就会大得有点离谱了对吧
而大家想想看我们的武器挂在那
武器是不是挂在手上
所以这个时候如果你动画压缩没有做好的话
你会发现就是压缩完了动画
你手上拿的这个武器啊
他会一直在那抖啊抖啊抖
那这里面给大家举个例子
比如说他最最糟糕的情况是什么呢
就是当你拿了一个长柄武器的时候
你会发现动画压缩
如果我做的不好
当这个角色做一个动作的时候
比如说我以前做halo的时候
我印象特别深
就是当时那个压缩就是我做的嘛
我做的第一版的时候
那个大块我们拿了一个很长的武器
他跳起来往地上一打的时候
你会发现那个动画是砸到地上的时候
就开始噔噔噔噔噔在那抖
就跟那个触电了一样
就特别明显
而且包括他另外一只手不是抓着它吗
那个那个那个饼和那个手
他一直是错开来的
就是一直这样就是浮空的
所以这就是动画压缩的时候
你会意识到
就是说不同的骨骼对于这个error
它的敏感度是完全不一样的
那这里面的话呢
就是我们用一些很简单的方法去定义这个error
比如说我们去marry他的CORTANA
它的TRANSTRANSLATION
他的rotation呢这样error
但这个error的定义是最简单的
但这个error呢其实是不符合人的perception的
因为我们动画压缩
本质上是希望你在人的认知上
不会产生这个差距
所以在行业里面
我们一般最关注的是什么呢
是visual error
就是视觉上的error
那世界的error呢最粗暴的做法是什么
我把模型上的所有的点对吧
用你的动画压缩完
和没有压缩前的数据进行比较
告诉你
这个就是叫我们像素级的差距到底是多少
大家想想这件事情怎么算
这个这个就算是你对不对
因为我有那么多动画
而且我每一帧都要算我几万个顶点
这不要死人吗
诶这个大家在行业里面
我们一般定义error的方法
实际上是定义两个垂直的点
就在每个joint的定义
两个垂直点给出一定的offset
那么如果你这个就是特别敏感一点
我这个offset给大一点
如果呢就是它是一个小骨骼或者不重要的骨骼
我的office给小一点
这个时候其实我用这个方法可以定量的去估计
说哎我的压缩前和压缩后
对于整个这个skeleton它的error到底产生了多少
其实我们比较一个两个压缩算法的好坏的时候
实际上也是用这个方法
但是呢其实今天我讲的是最简单的压缩算法
实际上这个动画压缩啊
在现代游戏引擎里面
是一个非常重要的研究领域
其实到现在我认为也没有解决的非常的好
那这里面呢会给大家讲一个比较
比较简单的方法吧
就是这里面的话就是我们会讲的是说
你在你骨架的不同位置的话
他这个对error的敏感度是不一样的
那这里面的话呢就是说有一个简单的想法
也是很直接的想法
就是说既然你的error会沿着我的股价
一直在往上传递传递传递传递传递嘛对吧
那我上一上一根骨架
假设压缩出来产生一个error的话
我下一个下一个joint的话
我能不能反向的对它进行补偿
这个是不是很符合我们的认知对吧
其实在我们的系统
比如说这个误差控制或者系统控制理论里面
经常有一种叫误差补偿的原理
就是这个原理
但是呢这个方法说起来是非常有道理的
但是你会发现
当你进行这种误差补偿的时候
实际上那个你本来在你的末端的这些骨骼
它以前的动画数据啊
是一个非常平滑的低频数据
但是他为了要补偿上面四五跟六七根骨骼
传递过来的error的时候
因为每一个骨骼它的频率不一样
这些频率压缩完产生的error会依次叠加
结果在你的这个终端骨骼上
会产生非常高频的这个数据
就导致了你的末端骨骼那个压动画压缩
第一个效果很差
第三个呢它会产生很多很奇怪的
这种就很高频的抖动
虽然你看到它的动动作不大
但是你会觉得有点怪
其实在现在有些很前沿的方法
就是说我会把一些末端骨骼
用一些那个会存在一个单独的
就是在这个模型坐标系的track
这个这个说法叫做forward f i k就是forward and inverse
conombic animation这个方法
但这个今天我不想看了
因为这个太复杂了
而且今天我的时间又超标了
我已经讲了快两个小时了
所以的话呢就跟大家讲就是动画压缩
当你们真的在做这个商业级的游戏引擎的时候
这个地方一定要小心
就是说第一个你的数据一定要压缩
但是呢你只要压得不好
或者你的方法选的不对
他一定会产生很多很奇怪的error
当你的artist要找你的时候
你就会把头发抓破
在想我到底哪一步做错了好
那最后呢就轻松一点吧
就跟大家讲讲这个动画到底是怎么做的对吧
就几页快速给大家讲一下
就是第一个呢就是说我们动画制作呢
首先呢你要去构建一个mesh
注意就是我们在前面讲过
就是我们的美术在构建mesh的时候
都是那种很高精度的mesh
但是呢那种非常高精度的mesh
实际上做动画做skinny的时候是很麻烦的
所以呢我们一般会用他的low poly mesh
就低精度的mesh去做他的这个动画
但这里面就有一个细节
就是说我为了保证这个动画的效果啊
在很多的关节的地方
我们的动画师会额外的加几拳的mesh
这样保证当你去动的时候
这个地方不会变形
所以说你们将来做一个引擎程序员的时候
当一个就是角色动起来的时候
你们会发现他们会在很多关键的地方
会加一些额外的一圈的网格
就像刚才这个视频中
我们的artist会在他的这个这个这个elbow
这个这个手肘这个地方
我们会加几拳的这个mesh
这个非常重要
那么接下来的话嗯
我们开始给他做股价
其实现代游戏引擎呢已经就
现在工具已经非常发达了
比如像3D max maya
它有现成的by pad的股价
所以当我们的artist做好了这个APOS或者TPOS的
这个这个这个角色的时候
他可以直接在工具里面拉出一个骨架
然后一个个的把它对上
这样的话我就可以完成一个
就是我可以定义了一个跟这个mesh相匹配的
这样一个绑定的这样的一个skeleton
而接下来呢也是最神奇的部分了哦
这里面还要再加上一些game play joint
比如说这里面我要加上他的这个武器的骨骼
对吧
然后呢我会再加上什么呢
我会再加上他的那个PV和root连连到底触的骨骼
因为很多工具
你们的这些骨骼会让需要你自己加
这个时候也是最重要的
就是它的skinny
那skinny呢是怎么做呢
就是现在很多工具呢它都是自动给你算出来的
就是其实自动的auto skinny
是现在比如说基于深度学习的这些一些前沿的
这个这个这个这个就是引擎的算法里面
我们很热点研究的东西
为什么呢
因为现在最简单的skinny啊
像很多3D max maya
他已经算的非常好了
但是呢他这个时候算出来的这个skinny
会让这个人看起来像像橡皮糖一样也很软
所以这个时候呢artist呢需要做一些手动的校正
就是这个地方诶
我希望关节的点在这
那这边的话呢就是这些权重
关节的其他权重不要传的太厉害对吧
他要手动做一些调整
但这个呢已经比之前要快非常非常多了
所以这个地方我一直用一个词叫pad
真的是那个我看动画生元素的时候
有时候真的像画那个颜色一样
五颜六色的
就是它那个颜色是代表的
就是每一根每一
比如说每个每一根骨骼
对我顶点影响的权重是多少
好那你有了这个之后呢
其实那个animator就开始做动画
做动画呢其实核心的思想
因为刚才我讲的live two d很像
就是说它并不会一帧一帧
就是一秒钟做30帧的
那不得了
动画师就下不了班了
对不对
他其实跟LOTOD一样
它只做它的关键帧
设置
每个关键帧之间的时间间隔
当这东西做好了之后
诶这个角色他就能动了
动起来
那么是这个时候
如果我们我们引擎的程序员干什么
我们要去写它的导出工具
这里面要讲一个细节
就是说大部分动画呢我们就直接导出
但是呢如果他的PVS
就是他的root假设也发生了位移
这个一般在什么时候会发生呢
就是说比如他发起跳跃的时候
这个root也在变
对不对
那我们会在动画里面root
一般是不会把它这个动画存下来
我们把root单独导成另外一个叫位移曲线
这个曲线给引擎用
所以呢这个是大家在写引擎的时候
一定要注意的一个小的细节
你有了这些东西的话
基本上一个完整的动画系统就已经实现了
所以呢这也是我们今天课程部分的话
最后一排就是说我们的数据
最后导致各种各样的那个文件格式
比如说FBX文件格式就是我们常用的一个格式
就是你今天在现代游戏引擎里面
游戏里面看到各种各样的DC的动画
各种精确的表达
它基本上万变不离其宗
就是用刚才那一整套的技术就能做出来
所以这个的话也就是大家很难想象
就是说我们用这种CORTANA
用这种matrix啊
用这种插值啊
卡特莫这些数据的变化
最后我们让电脑能够表达出这样一个fancy的
现代游戏的这个动起来的这个世界
所以我个人的话也是认为是动画系统
是一个几乎所有想做引擎
想做game play
想做这个游戏design的同学都要理解的一个系统
好今天我的课程部分差不多到这儿就啊结束了
接下来呢给大家讲一下
我们的上一节课的小作业
那首先呢首先非常开心啊
就是我们好多同学做完了我们的作业
然后又真的是很多神来一笔
就是说呃就是PIO引擎
我们一开始呢是没有color grading
大家看起来就这么简单对吧
但是我这边随便取了我们几个同学的作业呀
比如说我们这个同学就是无所谓同学做的作业
他这个滤镜就做的非常的专业
这个滤镜一看诶
有没有一点那个就是虚幻的感觉了对吧
其实我一直跟大家讲
就是这个所谓的大牌引擎
和一般的这个土鳖引擎区别很大
程度
我觉得至少有五成以上的区别是在滤镜上面
那么也有同学做的非常的有艺术感
这张我也蛮喜欢的
我觉得哇这个这个很像这个夕阳残雪
就是今天我讲的夕阳残雪
那么当然了
还有一些很神来之笔的
就比如说这个作品啊
当时那天我收到了之后
我就我就整个惊呆了
就这个同学说哎我是不是做了一个阴间滤镜
这个这肯定是写出了bug
但是大家也看到
就是说这个效果还是非常的魔幻的
假设我们作为一个非常魔幻风格的游戏的话
我觉得这也是个非常好的一个CD
这也是就是说其实SHADER代码
包括渲染它很有意思的一个地方
就是你会产生很多很有趣的一些效果
那么实际上的话呢就是说我们的引擎系统
这两这两周呢
我们在做这个进一步的去重新架构
就是说我们发现就是说作业的话
那同学们在里面写的时候
有些系统我们架的还是太难了
就是架的太抽象了
所以呢我们现在对这些系统
最近也在做进行一些升级和清理
就让他这个逻辑更简单
更方便
同学们
然后加入你们的代码
因为我们是希望就是呃
大家学了这个游戏引擎的这个克制化
一定要做一点点小小的实践
特别是你将来想立志做游戏啊开发和游戏
游戏引擎开发
那你做了一点小小的代码
其实你为了写那么一个小小的SHADER
你要看很多很多代码
这个时间其实这个过程肯定是比较麻烦的
这绝对比你做一个图形学的一个实验
要麻烦的多
但是的话呢你真的把这些代码
那个就是看明白的话呢
就是说你会真的掌握引擎
它是一个什么一个系统
包括就是说我们上周的话
大家也看到了
我们开始更新我们的wiki了
第一前两个wiki做的还是比较大
就比较high level的
就是我们讲一下最基础的数据流
其实后面随着我们的引擎的重构
我们会不断的就是想办法给同学们更新一下wiki
就是说大家如果有什么东西看不懂啊
不会用啊
不要不好意思
这是很正常的
就是你们就直接给我们提问
因为有的时候我们自己是平时做引擎
做的比较久嘛
我们有时候是没有感觉的
就觉得这东西应该很简单吧
就算大家应该能明白吧
但是等我们开始跟同学们讲课
包括我自己在准备课件
包括在收到同学们社区里面大家的反馈的时候
我才知道哦
原来这个地方我讲的好像有点超纲了对吧
我们想想怎么把它拉回来
那么所以这个地方的话呢
是一个我们社区共创的这样的一个过程
那么最后呢也给大家讲一下
这个也要请我们的社区大家一起帮忙
就是啊有同学告诉我们说
我们的PO的那个引擎这个名字太普通了
就是好多引擎很多技术点了
用了这个名字
他说我们那个PIO引擎
因为以后大家用的会比较多嘛
有可能会被大家说我们侵权了
虽然这个事情我们很委屈对吧
我们也没有任何商业的目的
所以呢后来我们就想了一下
我说要不这样
就大家伙一起这个
麻烦
大家
给我们的相遇琴取一个更好玩的一个名字对吧
比如我们也是P打头
但是叫一个什么
我们自己造个词觉得很酷
因为这个引擎就属于我们社区的对吧
那就是名字大家一起来取
所以的话呢我们就想了一个投票网站
大家可以在这个周四之前的话
大家觉得有什么有趣的名字
就直接在里面告诉我们
就在微信群里面告诉我们
然后的话这个社区里面那个扫二维码告诉我们
然后呢我们会在中间呢我想了一下
就是说我们会做一个小T恤
这么一个小的周边的纪念品
就是我们我们也不要说是选中了谁的名字
我们就给谁奖励对吧
这东西也不公平
每个人取名字都有自己的艺术
我们就随机的去试
十个同学给大家发一些纪念品
那么最重要的是说
希望能争取和大家一起
给我们的小引擎取个有意思的名字
因为这个这个小引擎的话
真的是可以带给大家
做很多大作业的一个利器吧
而且的话大家真的想引起我们一起摸啊
一起玩的话
大概我觉得就是半年到一年之后
会有很多同学建立对现代游戏的引擎的一个
基础的认知和基础的结构感好
那这个地方呢也是拜托大家给我们帮忙
那今天的课程基本上就这些了
其实啊虽然休息了一周
但其实我们的课程组的同学们还是蛮辛苦的
特别是最近我们在对引擎进行一次重构
就希望做的更简单
这里面有好多好多的工作量
包括我们自己连我都在一起跟大家去看代码
一起看怎么去弄好的
那今天就是我课程的全部了
那同学们有没有什么问题
啊OK第一个同学的问题是说
顶点绑定的关节有数量限制吗
对这个课程我讲过
就是说啊原则上是没有的
你可以绑50个关节
但是呢在实践中的话呢
我们一般只取最多不超过四个
他的原因其实很简单
就是说如果绑了太多之后
你在计算的时候
那个计算量是非常非常大的
那么你每个顶点都算一遍的话
这个这个就很废了
另外一个就是其实我们对关节
一个角色的关节数量的话呢
一般我们会做一些控制
比如说最多不会超过255个
为什么呢
因为0~256
是不是正好用一个BT就可以去表达
比如说我我要存的那个绑定的
那个叫joint index的话
我用一个八位的
一个一个一个八个beat的
这样的一个BT就可以表达
这样的话我存储上
包括数据访问上效率就会高很多
因为这个数据是每个顶点都要存的
所以说对这是有一定限制的
哇这个问题有点难
有同学问我说骨骼和场景碰撞的动画怎么做的
这个其实是蛮难的
因为其实你你们我们会发现啊
就是很多所谓能和场景交互的
这个就是说这些动画的话
它实际上呢就是我并不是拿一根根
骨骼和场景算
这个其实很麻烦
因为实际上我当我们动物
一个角色的骨骼的时候
其实我们看到了那个就是这些这些skinny
就是我们看到这个表面的这些模型
实际上只是一个visual的看的东西
它真正和场景互动的是什么呢
是钢铁
就是我们会做一个richard body的一个顾客
这个我们在物理那怕你会跟大家去讲
就是说比如说我们人身上有75个对吧
一直到星期道小手指小手指
但是呢我们在做它的这个物理的相关的时候
我只用了其中十几根骨骼
动了一些诶简简单单的圆柱或者方块
然后呢
这些圆柱和方块呢
确实是可以和静态的场景发生碰撞的
比如说我拿了一个刀对吧
我拿了个刀砍下去
这个刀砍到墙上去
那其实是我刀上在我这个这个joint上面
就是这个关节上绑了一个
就是刚才我讲了拿武器的关节上
我绑了一个他的read body
它撞到那个墙的时候
诶我可以算出来它的焦点在哪里
这个时候我可以跟沿着你的切割的那个轨道
形成火星
包括就是在很多游戏里面
现在很多引擎里面都是这样
就是说诶你这个人突然打出一拳或者做个动作
但前面有个东西的时候
他这一拳会停止掉
甚至会变成另外一个动画
那这个里面的话
它实际上不是用那个skinny matrix去做了
他实际上是用的那个叫rigid body
Read the body
会告诉你说我的这个动画放到比如说D
比如说我这个clips有100个pose对吧
我可能放比如一个攻击动作
我100个pose我可能放到第16个的时候
我就动不了了
因为我已经撞到一个东西了
这个时候我立马切到另外一个clip
就是我这个这个攻击失败了
我说我这个手很疼
对
所以说这样
他是用另外一套系统解决这个问题的
啊这个同学问我说
MF target的动画和蒙皮动画是不是侧重点
是不是只是侧重点不同啊
这个呢他两个的方法其实差别还是蛮大的
蒙皮动画呢
你核心动的是它的那个joint或者叫骨骼
然后呢通过骨骼就是一个骨骼可以驱动啊
几十个甚至上百个顶点
所以顶点上其实是不会存动画数据的
但是more ftie的动画呢
它存的是那些顶点的位置
就是每一组顶点的位置
就是他的一个key friend
然后呢
我我的顶点在它的KF1
K分之二之间进行插值
这就是move target的动画
他两个的话方法其实非常不一样
就是more发给动画的
更像是我刚才讲的那个vertex animation
就顶点动画
所以呢这个在下一节课的时候
我们讲人的脸怎么做的
人脸上的表情怎么做的时候会讲的比较清楚
特别是大家特别喜欢的那个捏脸系统
好的今天的时间也比较长了
现在已经是两个小时零五分了
我们又刷了这个课程记录
所以今天的话呢我们的动画的第一节先到这
谢谢大家
那我们争取下周再跟大家见面
OK好拜拜